a lawyer representing two Pittsburgh
high school students plans to sue the
school and police for what they claim is
a pattern of abuse abuse targeting black
students video of one incident shows a
school resource officer putting a
student in a headlock before pushing him
down and then later using a Taser
vladimir duthiers of our streaming
network cbsn has the school's response
the video recorded in March 2015 shows
Ahmad Williams waiting in the
principal's office after being sent
there by a teacher he's exchanging words
with school resource officer Steve
shallows suddenly shallots confronts
Williams putting him in a headlock and
eventually dragging him to the hallway
principal Kevin Murray helps officer
shallows hold Williams down while a teen
is handcuffed and tasered at a press
conference Williams attorney Todd Hollis
said this is one of three known
incidents at Woodland Hills School
District the picture speaks a thousand
words and that picture in that picture
clearly does this picture clearly does
then a video has to speak a million in
another alleged incident in November
audio appears to capture principal
Murray scolding a student found on
school property after hours third
incident in early April shows student K
Sean Wade restrained by two police
officers and taken into a room off
camera principal Murray is seen walking
in and out of the room Hollis claims
Wade was then punched in the face by
Officer Sharla's Superintendent Alan
Johnson says the incidents do not
represent a pattern what mr. Hollis has
done here is taken two or three isolated
incidents over the course of several
years in a building with 1,700 students
and has managed to weave that into a
conspiracy the attorney for principal
Murray says he did not physically
violate anyone who was only responding
to the officer's actions he also says
the audio is taken out of context he was
only repeating what the students said to
the teacher he is also the attorney for
Officer Sharla's he says Hollis
continues to serve the district and is
cooperating with the investigation
Charlie glad thank you so much